[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the realm table of
dim lighting we are going to be talking
about your romantic mishaps you answered
our question that we put out there on
the internet which was ever had a
romantic plan completely fall apart
whether you planned it or someone
planned it for you we want to know your
romantic mishap stories so that we can
laugh in your face
you know sometimes love goes sideways
Rhett
Hey listen you can go any way you want
that's your preference I you know what I
got a number of friends who like
um
they talk about their first date or like
an early
romantic encounter with the person that
they've been with for like years maybe
decades now and like the the best
stories are the ones that like start off
sideways like you hate each other or
something catches on fire or like uh you
know venereal disease
spoiler alert I haven't read any of
these I'm just saying just a
metaphorical venereal disease okay
nothing catches yeah something catches
on fire oh I just I mean I look at the
teaser I can look at the the titles of
the
the things that we have to go through
here yeah you you looked at the titles
this time I didn't because I was look I
was working on something else now what
about super gonorrhea though
uh I cannot speak intelligently about
this nor from personal experience do you
know what I'm talking about
I'm not talking about my that year I was
a superhero called super gonorrhea no
I'm talking about
um drug resistant gonorrhea okay
so obviously drug resistant bacteria
in I guess viruses are something that we
were all talking about and all really
scared of until covet happened and then
we got distracted or I you know moved to
that crisis but now that we are
hopefully uh that crisis is subsiding
now staring us straight in the face is
the drug resistant bugs that we will be
facing uh in the we are already facing
millions of people dying of this already
worldwide Millions more will die soon
I mean let's just make this about me and
super gonorrhea no I don't think it
necessarily kills you but uh from what I
know of it
I mean is it just if you're like it's
gonorrhea that you can't treat it like
your legs are spreading a Ralphs and you
can get it
um no I think you got to get it from
somebody else with super gonorrhea okay
so but the point I'm making is that
great you said that some some of the
best
stories I love stories start with things
going sideways and I'm just saying I
wonder if there's a super gonorrhea
becomes a super awesome relationship and
I'm doubting if that's the case Okay
that was the joke portion of my setup
hey safe sex guys all right
wear wear a condom
um you know what not two though don't
wear two we know we learned that from
our sex September we learned that from
uh the GMM episode where we talked about
like uh questions that kids ask
that that's what we learned really yeah
when we were singing about
uh sex ed questions okay if you wear two
condoms the friction
the the chances of one of the condoms
actually rupturing is much increased
yeah because the friction it'll burn it
it'll it'll start a fire yeah that's
where the fire it's like it's like a
racing
okay so that's a negative thing can I
throw in a positive thing to keep this
thing up because I am I'm riding High
you didn't even think I was going to be
here today man we're recording at a
completely different time than I had
planned for and prepared for
but we're still good we're still good
we're actually bet I'm the I'm so good
I'm so grateful I'm feeling so great
because I am free I have been released
from jury duty I got the thing I've been
calling in all week you have to call in
at like 7 p.m at night for the next day
yeah last night
it was it was a a Wednesday night what's
the day Thursday or Friday yeah
and I had made it through I made it
through Monday I made it through Tuesday
I made it through Wednesday and then oh
no I gotta go in I gotta be in there at
eight o'clock and this is the second
time downtown L.A we've both been called
or summoned some to be on a you know to
be considered for a jury yeah multiple
times I've called all week
I think three times since I've been in
La I've never been summoned never been
summoned and you said this was something
second time is it what you think it's it
can be like some alphabetical I'm super
summonable man yeah but they don't know
anything I say about me oh he is so
summitable
yeah I mean is there something about I
mean I don't know what it is it's
glasses they think you've got better
judgments it's my sense of justice they
don't know that you've got glasses
it's my sense of justice I'm known for
that
uh was I was
ushered into some holding room I mean
there was like over a hundred people in
there the more the less likely it is for
you to be called they started calling
people over the loudspeaker just
listening out names and at what like and
then people would just get up and just
just go off into Oblivion never to be
heard of again
see anybody you recognize
nope I'm like I mean like where's LeBron
James in all this it's kind of what I'm
thinking nobody no nobody escapes it
nobody escapes it man I mean no one it's
a civic duty they're civic duty man yeah
yeah and I'm you know I'm happy to do it
and I I did it and it didn't take long
but I got scared man you know 15 people
go away 25 people go away and then
they're like all right for this next one
it's going to be a 30-day trial
so when I call your name you either yell
out yes or no based on whether you have
a valid excuse
and they give you the excuses and they
give they give the excuses you can
choose from like one of them is you
gotta paid you've paid for a vacation
that is non-refundable wow I'm like if
you you know what I'm I'm looking for
all types of reasons to like plan
another
non-refundable vacation like not you
know when you're if if you play any sort
of vacation like even if you do like an
Airbnb for one night
after you're you've prepared yourself to
pay Pony up whatever you got to Pony up
there's always this like oh and do you
want to add insurance like it's kind of
like when you go to rent a car and
they're like oh do you want to add
insurance and it's like oh what you want
to do you know I've got an insurance if
you've got it through your credit card
yeah that's what I think but now I'm
like oh I'm not adding insurance to a
vacation because I could get called in
for jury duty and this is this is my out
I did not get called
um for this for the 30 day good gracious
because and you have and one of the
excuses valid excuses is if you're
self-employed self-employed and so it's
like a company it you put your company
live uh livelihood at risk you know
and there's so much that we're doing
here that like I was prepared to give
some sort of speech to like lawyers and
judge that was like let me show you my
important work that I do there's a lot I
mean look at this hair I don't I think
everyone in this in the proceedings will
be totally distracted by this hair yeah
and plus I got you know I don't want to
I got all these people who just be
sitting on their hands you know it's
like I'm kind of central to this stuff
I'm not trying to toot my own horn here
I think I could go a month without you
but but uh you know it would shut down
production everybody's just waiting for
me to show back up again but you but
there were like maybe a few days I was
prepared to talk about that apparently
but then they kept calling kept calling
and they said a couple of Charles's and
let me tell you every time
every time they would say a CH name
boy my pucker string would just tighten
up what did you think I was nervous man
it was as if I was on trial here's I
mean first of all and when I think
everyone needs to everyone needs to
perform their civic duty I did and I do
think that at some point I was there for
later in my life I would actually like
to be a part of this system right now
not a great time I'm curious yeah
um I want to be able to like I want I
want to be a juror before I die but my
question for you or while I'm dying that
would be interesting is because uh
is because I think that last thing I do
you
like if if I were in your shoes and
again I haven't actually been called in
every time I've made the phone call
don't have to come in but if I found out
the night before that I was gonna have
to go you're not summonable
I would have gone on YouTube
and I would have like done some research
about what I could well I would say
again I want to be clear I'm not saying
I'm avoiding this forever I'm just
saying that right now really
inconvenient there's a lot even three
days right now throws a lot of we
everything is planned here in such so
far Advanced that I don't like to throw
that wrench into the system here
but my assumption is that you did not do
any sort of preparation no I was in
complete denial that it was ever going
to happen until the moment it happened
because you would have a much more and
then when I woke up this morning
interesting story if you went there and
you had to go to the next stage and
answer questions because at that point I
was so close to that last time there's a
way to answer the questions that is
honest but still kind of throws them off
your scent a little bit if you're a long
time you're biscuits listener you can go
back in time I don't know when that was
back when I had to go to like it was a
different Courthouse I told that whole
story
um I don't even remember it I'll go back
and listen to it to know what happened
to me but
they kept calling they kept saying not
other Charles's and then
it was like oh we got there at eight and
it was like 11 30 by this time they
probably called
um seven different groups seven
different cases and the people just file
out because that's the interesting part
from what I understand is the next part
where I've experienced the case I've
experienced that and then they start
describing things and asking specific
questions oh yeah they interrogate you
to see if they want to put you on the
stand yeah not on the stand in the jury
box yeah and then they suddenly you're
defining yourself that's what I've
already talked about man go back to the
archives yeah if you want to be but you
didn't have but you didn't have to get
up on that that you didn't have to
answer she comes over the loudspeaker no
and she just says
good news for all of you who are still
sitting in here
you have performed your duty to
completion
you're free to go and we're going to
give you a slip on the way out you can
sign it on you at your leisure but keep
it keep up with that thing because
you're good for the next 12 months and
they're saying if you get summoned you
have to present this well it's proof why
doesn't the system yes proof If the
system tries to drag you in again and
let me tell you when she made that
announcement
everybody in there cheered like it it
felt like I had been exonerated like
everybody in there was just kind of
looking at each other like we did it
we're innocent well the courthouse is
kind of like a doctor's office even if
there's nothing wrong with you you feel
like you're that close to Justice being
dispensed yeah it may come out sideways
oh it could go wrong here it was I mean
it was great to be in like a government
facility in like a holding room for
hours and then to receive news that
every single person in there was elated
like that was that was a moment
everybody needs that every once yeah it
just felt so good like we just all
strutted out of there like we had done
something and we hadn't done anything
we hadn't done anything you've done more
than I have
but I was ready I was ready to give my
speech to say why I couldn't perform my
civic duty because my civic duty is
employing people huh you know what
can you take a camera in there no
because we could I mean I'm just saying
you can make it content yeah you can't
talk about it you know what we can oh I
would talk about in code you could uh
video glasses spy glasses I believe
juror number seven
what if I just had a big shoulder camera
yeah he's definitely filming this this
is my emotional support camera it's not
on yeah right
I mean it's just nice to to be out in
the world again you know uh the fresh
air like I was just looking at the sun
just like beaming down on me and the
Beautiful downtown Los Angeles streets
and I was just
I got a new lease on life man okay well
let's ride that high into some romantic
mishaps but first let's talk about the
latest quarterly collectible from the
mythical Society it is issue number two
of our comic book series Rhett and links
Blood Oath you know how we do every
quarter if you're a third degree member
of the mythical Society we create a
physical good
that is completely unique and totally
exclusive to uh those mythical Society
members you can be a monthly quarterly
or annual subscriber and it's I mean
there's so many other things with the
mythical Society people talk about how
they're like tired of us talking about
it but I just can't stop
it's just who says it's such a such a
positive thing people the people who
aren't paying for it and wish they could
get it for free but but it's worth
paying for especially when it's like we
put our heart and soul and creativity
and collaboration with fan tunes into
the second edition of this uh comic book
which features
Jade and Barbara our favorite dogs yep
well oh
is Sean now your favorite dog I mean uh
Jasper's giving Jay to run for money but
it'll never happen I don't know if if
Sean keeps up his uh Antics I don't
believe that he can he can replace
Barbara who did he is he still biting
people he bought he uh he bit
um he bit Shepard's girlfriend
is she okay yeah you like bitter jeans
yeah yeah yeah hey it hurt when he bit
me through my sweat britches
my sweat britches
um so go to mythical Society sign up for
third degree quarterly or annual by the
end of March am I right
in order to be able to qualify to get
that comic book it's the collector's
item
you might get reamed on eBay otherwise
10 years down the road and there's a lot
more to offer over there at the mythical
Society a lot of content a lot of events
a lot of community that you can only
experience at mythicalsociety.com
[Music]
brought to you by betterhelp you know
sometimes when I'm feeling stressed out
want to clear my head a little bit reset
I like to do some breathing exercises
those have proven to be very very
helpful you want you build your lungs up
right get those muscular lungs but
sometimes
I do the breathing
and then on the other side of the
breathing that thing that I was trying
to breathe my way through is still there
yeah
and sometimes you don't know what it is
right I mean sometimes you need a
professional to give some input I'm
talking about a therapist y'all when you
try everything you can to de-stress and
you're still feeling a bit flustered
like Rhett was talking about therapy can
give you even more tools to clear your
mind the breathing is still very very
important but sometimes there are
tangible things that you need to discuss
and discover
and kind of walk through with a
professional that you're just not going
to get to on your own and therapy can
really help with just about anything
you're looking to improve with yourself
sometimes it can just be hard to get
started but better help makes that
easier yes because it's entirely online
convenient and affordable you just fill
out a questionnaire they match you with
a licensed therapist that meets your
needs and listen
the the chances that you want to switch
are there so they've they've accounted
for that if you ever want to switch
therapists you can at no extra cost if
you want to live a more empowered life
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com ear today to get 10 off
your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash ear
foreign
let's get to some emails of course you
can always call us and females
voicemails voicemails at 1-88
earpod one did I say four eights
you know what I mean
you have to hit that hello you have to
hit the plate oh I gotta hit the play
button
hey Rhett link
um calling my name is Abby calling about
my romantic mishap story
um I'm gonna try to make this short but
the this is about eight or nine years
ago I had a really big crush on this guy
it was like my crush is bigger than his
crush on me
um eventually after you know me pining
over this guy he came over to hang out
one night
because uh the weekend it was really
late
um a guy on drugs basically broke into
my apartment while we were hanging out
um I lived on the second floor of a
duplex
um and this old old building
and the locks and stuff I guess weren't
that great he basically busted through
the door
um and jumped he didn't even look at us
he we're sitting on the couch he just
busted through the door ran up the
stairs busted through the door
um opened the window to the roof didn't
look at us went on the roof and was
hanging out on the roof
um I called 911 immediately the guy I
was with was completely useless this
kind of diminished that crush on him my
roommate comes out she's the nicest
person to ever meet and she's trying to
coax this guy back into the into the
house and I'm like no I'm calling 9-1-1
get this guy out of here he's obviously
on bath salts
um you know from 10 years ago in the
height of bass solved she's trying to
coax them in with like ice cream and
she's like come on in please like come
in it's so cold like I'm like Julie stop
like what are you doing anyway
um ruin the night and uh but now we have
a story to tell when the bath salt guy
broke into our house anyway he fell off
the roof he did he landed in the snow
bank the police ended up catching him it
all worked out whatever never saw him
again he didn't hurt us but it was a
pretty intense night so love you guys
thanks for the opportunity to tell you
my story okay bye he fell off the roof
into a snowbank
he's okay so that's why she was trying
to coax him in with the ice cream
because she was afraid he was going to
jump off the roof which he did so bath
salts made it out of Florida I guess
because there's no snow banks in Florida
um
but the Crush
was completely useless
which gives me a great idea I'm with
everybody that we could offer yes I
think that there is something to this
creating a situation that becomes an
intense yet pointed judge of your
potential partner's character
wherewithal anything whatever you know
what is it that you're interested in
right we can we can construct that
immersive experience and we send
somebody well they might be on bath
salts and yeah I mean and I'm using um
quote quotations because I'm not you
know he's acting like he's on basketball
right because we're doing a service now
and he's actually doing it but if he
needs to jump off that roof he will do
the stunt man we have we have every we
have a person for that right right uh we
also have like if you're going to go on
a date and you want to test the like
Fidelity meter of your potential mate
and maybe this is like hey maybe we're
three four dates in first you need to
tell us what a Fidelity meter is well
what I'm saying is that okay okay we'll
work on let's say that you are a man who
is dating a woman
and uh it happens you are the woman uh
hires us to see if oh Fidelity the man
is uh I was thinking like audio Fidelity
okay well you're a DJ I can't help it
and so Elkhound the uh the test we would
have an attractive uh woman who would at
a certain point in the evening would
come in and flirt with the man as a test
and then she would have on the video
glasses just to throw back there because
we have to have evidence this is the
kind of like cheaters and then if like
if if if if he does not succumb to her
advances then she's like well I'm just
gonna go up and jump off the roof and
then see what he does we don't have to
have a jumping off I think they're all
going to jump off the roof there's all
but we will provide the snow bank every
time yeah that sounds seems like an
unnecessary expense we'll work out the
Kinks our resources are unlimited I mean
they just given this is such a Far and
Away the best business idea we've ever
had I think all we've really done test
your mate is created a series of hard to
watch social experiment YouTube videos
which are the kind of I just I mean I
just don't like those videos man and you
know what I'm talking I'm talking about
the completely fake ones fabricationed
yeah and I just it is nice to know I
mean it's like this is good data if it's
like uh your crush just completely
implodes if that's something you're
if that's something you that's
attractive to you then you've learned
something it's not something that's not
attractive to you
then you've also learned something
anything that happens
when you're dating somebody is a
learning opportunity that's a that's
what I want that's what I want to impart
like dating is
it's just be curious
do you know everything can teach you
something
you know well my wife has never let me
live a particular situation down and
that was early in our marriage when we
were walking down
Franklin Street in Chapel Hill North
Carolina where we were living at the
time
I had to do some time in Chapel Hill
I uh
there was a man who was acting erratic
and he was on the street on the sidewalk
and we walked past him and according to
Jesse's account of this story he
he was kind of erratic and it seemed
like he was getting potentially
aggressive in multiple directions
including while we walked by her
Direction and at which point I moved
away from him
behind her no no it was like we were is
this what happened I remember her saying
behind her no I didn't according to the
story has grown over the past 20 years
to me like literally taking her and
pushing her at him and running yeah you
ever see one of those like like a keeper
you see how a keeper just kind of lays
out trying to like save the you know
save the score what I will say I did and
it was a mistake it was a mistake is
that
I moved away from him she was closer to
him my assumption was that if she was
also threatened I wasn't actually
threatened but I was kind of like this
guy's a little squirrely I don't know
what's going to go on I'll step away
from him I was kind of expecting her to
also step away but she will never let me
live down the fact that I did not step
in front of her and like create like a
big red barrier yeah and I'm I'm sorry
that's your foot I mean there isn't what
did she learn she learned that I guess
every single time we're walking on a
sidewalk every man for himself any kind
of character that seems to be exhibiting
uh abnormal behavior that might lead to
an incident
which happens quite often in Los Angeles
she is like her her radar is up now her
she didn't have to be now she's not
worried about being hurt by someone
she's worried about are you gonna do the
thing that you banned 20 years ago yeah
and so now uh boy you you got ought to
see the way I can box out at this point
I mean it doesn't even have to there
could be absolutely nothing about the
person's behavior and I'll I'll put a
full butt into them just to kind of
create a barrier between them and my
wife you know just full box out position
it could just be like an old woman ready
to cross the street I'm not helping her
across the street I'm keeping her away
from my wife erotic old woman
um my
romantic fail I'm sure there's been many
but the one that comes to mind right now
is it was just it was pre-pandemic but
it might have been 2019
when I took Christy on a Valentine's
date
um we went to Malibu and I had I'd found
I'm sure I talked about it on here and
I'm I probably made it seem like it was
a success I can't remember how I couched
it but now I feel like it was kind of
yeah I would never do that would I
um I found those tapes where we were
like the cassette tapes where the long
distance walkie-talkie where uh we would
send cassette tapes back and forth and
we keep adding to it and then when I
played it
I surprised her that I'd found them
because they were lost for years yeah
and I revealed the surprise by just
playing the first tape for her and after
a few minutes it was just like
what I thought would be this sweet
romantic thing was just kind of like it
was so cringy that we just couldn't I
think we it's like we couldn't keep
listening who was cringier uh we were
both pretty cringy like our accents
were like it was like we were just
children I mean we learned a lot it was
like wow it's just like
we are not the same people we were
but I just remember it just wasn't
it didn't it it wasn't enticing it
didn't it definitely didn't lead to a
makeout session
um I see that I could see that but the
and we were and then we went through the
drive through not a drive through we
went through the exit and there were so
many cars leaving this place there was
somebody behind us beside us in a
Drive-Thru and we were beside him and
then they were having some hanky-panking
in the car oh like there was like some
some hand hanky-panky happening handjobs
I believe it was like that yeah whoa it
was crazy how did you know that you're
peering in it was broad daylight and I
was looking at their faces this is a low
car it was like a Mini Cooper no I
wasn't able to look all I could see was
like shoulders and heads you can tell
what people are doing with their hands
by looking at their shoulders and heads
given her reaction I could definitely
tell that's our service we also
something was definitely going on that
wasn't happening in my car at roof
jumpers we also
offer the service of being able to go
through a parking lot and tell people
tell what is happening by looking at
people's heads and shoulders there's
nothing there's nothing worse than being
on what you hope to be like a romantic
date and Valentine's Day is built up so
much and you're in your car cringing
about
like your accents from college and you
look over next to you and and they're
like in a in full pleasure mode and you
know it's like it's just kind of
dejecting and you're thinking back on a
time when you weren't even kissing
because you were yeah so conservative
yeah yeah that sucks man I was like
I'll have what they're having
this is a great segue into number 11
link oh number 11. yeah right yeah
because I did a little pre-screening
don't always do that but had the time
today because you were
at jury duty so now I can do cool
Segways right
hey Rhett link mythical crew my name is
Mandy I'm from Seattle big fan anyways
I'm calling to share a story about a
romantic mishap so buckle up okay so I
was a senior in high school at the time
and I was finally dating the guy diet
that I had had a crush on since middle
school thank God and for the sake of
story we'll just call him Peter we're
not together now we were together for
five years and it was our first
Valentine's Day together and so we went
out we saw a movie pretty early in the
afternoon and we have some time to kill
before our dinner reservation so we
opted to go down by the river in town
and watch the sunset before heading to
the restaurant uh we did watch the
sunset but we also got a little like
frisky I guess nothing too crazy uh we
were making out our clothes stayed on uh
anyways I guess we kind of lost track of
the time and the sun was definitely down
as in it was Pitch Black outside uh so
we were making out the back of his car
and all of a sudden we see a huge
blinding light aimed directly at us
through the windshield and in my head
I'm like okay we're being abducted like
by an alien anything else to go off
though since we couldn't see uh then we
hear a loud knock on the door and it's a
freaking police officer and he tells us
to get out and he accuses us of doing
more than just making out which clearly
was not the case since we were fully
clothed and all that
um he was super rude and demanded to see
our IDs and then when I that was when I
realized I had left mine at home but she
really didn't like and then he was
saying like do your parents know you're
here maybe I should give them a call
which really just pissed me off because
we were clearly not doing anything else
uh so Peter explains that we're killing
time before the reservation and he lets
us go unfortunately I spent the rest of
the night almost crying because I was so
shaken up and unfortunately Peter spent
the rest of the night laughing at me
almost crying uh so it was really rough
we had better Valentine's days after
that I guess it was the cops job for
that Valentine's Day to like make sure
people weren't doing the dirty next to
the boat launch uh but yeah that's my
story love you guys
what's wrong with doing the dirty next
to the boat launch especially if you're
in a car
I don't know
I don't know I think we should have
designated places for this
um this is an interesting question about
what is the motivation is there an
actual I mean okay yeah you can't go to
Disneyland and be you know porking in
the parking lot you know what I'm saying
you can't do that
there have to be some standards but if
you've got a van
and you can't see into it I think you
should be able to do whatever you want
to in your van right when we were young
we used to uh I think you were with me a
few times yeah we would around the
country where we lived there were a
number of college students who would
roll out somewhere into like a field
and there was like they would pop in
their car and we would and we would find
them we would find them and we would
find them and not because we were
looking for them uh I do remember once
once you found them we were looking for
him after that most of the time it was
like can we from a distance see
something that you know you want to see
usually the windows were too fogged up
or whatever but there's a couple of
spots where it was like reliably people
would come yeah I remember one time I
don't know if you were with us this time
I seem to remember that we it was it was
that field now there's a the second like
18 holes of Keith Hills are over there
but it was kind of near Ben's house
right in that little farm pond yep and
they were behind the farm pond and it
was like in my mind it was a pinto it
was like a pinto wagon and it was
bouncing up and down vigorously
vigorously
and super fogged and we just walked
right up to it
like just dumb little 12 year olds man
just like we're gonna walk right up to
this and we walk touch it and run away
and then we didn't touch it were you
there for this
it's I don't know I know the story and I
visualized it but I think it was because
you told it to me and then I just maybe
fantasized such vigorous detail yeah
well I don't know who was with us it
might have been
[Applause]
and then like we stand there for
15 20 seconds at which point
the girl sees us now we couldn't see
anything but like at one point like I
see this head pop up and look at us in
absolute horde all of a sudden it's like
they just go away I'm sorry
if you went to Campbell University in
approximately 19 between 1988 1992 and
you were engaging first of all it was
illegal at the time and maybe still
illegal to have someone of the opposite
sex in your room if you were called at
Campbell University in the 80s or 90s
with a girl in your room and you were a
guy you would be kicked out of school we
had a guy that was on the basketball
team that got expelled because he had a
girl in his room what
so if you wanted to do the dirty you had
to get into a car and go to the farm
pond right and I'm sorry that I took
what may have been a beautiful
experience and I ruined it
and uh whatever I could do to make up
for it just contact us at 1-88
please do that if you want to reach out
to people who went to Campbell between
88 and 92 and got interrupted by a
couple of 12 year olds while having sex
but back to this story Peter as she
called him totally got cop blocked yeah
he got caught blocked yeah okay I had to
had to go back to that all right what
are we clicking on now another VM
I forget I have to do this
hey Rhett and Link uh my name is Ben
from Harrisburg Pennsylvania long time
Watcher first time
uh voicemail
uh so I'm replying to the Tweet uh we
know the Romantic plan completely
falling apart uh this one time I invited
this girl over and I was attempting to
make spaghetti for her like super simple
is that are you familiar you can't you
can't possibly mess that up but um
long story short uh I ended up my my
stove ended up catching on fire
and so uh you know I I had to grab the
fire extinguisher and I had to put it
out and then the rest of the night me
and her were uh
we were cleaning up the debris from the
uh fire extinguisher oh it can be a lot
that was fun
uh it was a nice bonding experience
um and to answer your and to answer
inquiring minds no we're not together
anymore all right for the best all right
so have a great day guys love y'all
uh yeah so yeah love you yeah so if
we're using this to gather evidence and
gather evidence gather data to then
bring in to roof jumpers which first of
all I don't like that name yeah we got
to change that name there is a there's a
snow thing there every time but let's
change the name yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
because it's no one gets hurt no one
gets hurt
um but if we're Gathering data this
would lead me to believe that a fire
isn't necessarily a good thing to do on
a first date because they didn't end up
staying together and you know what they
they cleaned it together like that was
an opportunity yeah it's this is this is
really a great story for a couple that
needs to stay together to the point
where he had to tell us that they did
you know it's like maybe
I don't know I don't wanna
he could have gone another way you know
could have gone the other way I do think
that when you're on a date
the earlier in the relationship the
better and something goes horribly wrong
it's like you got to recognize the
opportunity there's data to be gathered
and there's a story to be had and it's
you know you're gonna face adversity you
might as well go ahead and see how your
love interest responds it can also but
don't unleash a fire extinguisher I mean
it just does just put a lid on it or
something the one with the powder now if
you've got the CO2 one you're okay which
I don't even know where you get those
but the ones you just if you just go to
Like Home Depot and get a fire
extinguisher it's gonna be the one
that's uh particulate and boy that stuff
is we've we've probably heard us talk
about this many many times before you
play the next one I'm not gonna I do
want to talk about
um
sometimes a traumatic experience can
I want to use the term artificially
accelerate a relationship yeah uh but
sometimes that's good
case in point
when Jesse and I were dating
and we haven't been dating for long you
know we had like a slow build in our
relationship yeah where we were friends
yeah as I was waiting for her to get to
College yeah and she had to not be a
child anymore yeah
okay that's not cool man
it's a different time and also I was
waiting for her to be in college before
we dated and I did okay you did you know
I didn't start dating her when she was
18. I waited until she was in college at
almost 19. but
the relationship moved pretty quickly
and
her grandmother died
and I remember two sort of visceral the
the visceral experience was
actually going into the hospital room
and I never I maybe one time had met her
grandmother
um you went in the hospital room
yes this was a date well it wasn't a
date we were dating but why why don't
you just let her go in you didn't even
know this woman
um well because I mean it was getting
pretty serious emotional support is the
correct answer and there you go uh but
it was what you're getting at it's
actually one of the images in my I don't
like hospitals
um
and I always get I you know I just I
have a health anxiety and I just don't
like being in the space
but I haven't seen a lot of like heavy
stuff that takes place at hospitals in
my life I have but one of the more the
one of the heavier things was going in
there and basically seeing her
grandmother
in the final stages of life
and uh like unconscious too
at the time
but it was like a little bit traumatic
and we experienced it together and then
days later her grandmother dies we you
know there's the funeral
and it was after the funeral I was like
sitting on the couch
uh at her house where I ended up
unplanned and this is not you know I
tend to be pretty spontaneous about life
and I'm very flexible in general but
when it comes to things like when I'm
going to say I love you or when I'm
going to do this I tend to be a little
bit more buttoned up and planned
and I had not planned on saying I love
you and I ended up telling her that I
loved her really and it was because her
grandmother died and because we
experienced that thing together now in
our case it worked out great
we've been married for 20 something
years
um but you got to be careful when you
experience something a little bit
traumatic because it might artificially
accelerate things
it's just not about Gathering data you
gotta you got to know that there's
potential for things to like for the
accelerator to be hit pretty hard
well when Christy and I started dating
we hadn't been dating long when I broke
my pelvis and had that like the whole
concussion story yeah you know and so I
I remember that my mom was so you know
we were in the mountains we were like
hours away and my mom was so concerned
and she was like talking to Christy on
the phone like they were commiserating
and then like Chris once I came back I
stayed at the apartment I didn't go home
with my mama and so like Christy was
coming by checking on me and like giving
my mom updates
you know just kind of like
instead of my mom trying to figure
everything out just by what I was
telling her when she would come visit it
kind of gave her another point to like
Christy comforted my mom and of course
me yeah in that in that time when I
broke my ass and that that was
definitely uh formative you know the
fact that like he got somebody caring
for you like actively physically and um
because she was in that it wasn't
Christy
because we I we haven't showed this yet
and I think we may at some point on the
society but one of the tapes that we
found was me impromptuing
a song about you having uh busted your
ass having broken your pelvis I don't
think Christy was there for that but she
was there for so much of that footage
she might have been there for some of
that but around that same time
definitely she was in the yeah she was
in that that footage that I Unearthed
the other thing is
um we were pretty we were pretty serious
but then like I went away for the summer
yeah a junior year
no was it sophomore year yeah sophomore
year summer after sophomore year
we have been dating that whole year so
that summer we were apart
and I had to fly back because my mom's
dad that Papa passed away in 1998.
and Christy
like we were spending the summer apart
and like it was difficult for us
and but we were ready for me to be away
for 10 weeks and for us just to
communicate that way it's when um it's
when we were doing the the walkie-talkie
that I was talking about earlier but I
came home to see my grandfather uh
uh in his last day like I made it home
before he passed away and then he passed
away and like she she showed up and like
she spent the day with me and then the
next day she went to to the funeral with
me and like you were out of town like uh
and all of my friends were gone
and it
um that was a very formative time yeah
for us
of course I still didn't say I love you
because I had this like idea that I
don't say I love you until I'm getting
engaged of course of course like
everybody
still worked out that was that was a big
deal for us and you know honestly going
to weddings
uh with somebody that you're dating I
think it's just that I think that's more
of a danger like you have this tale of
like when tragedy hits I actually think
that's pretty good but like when you
when going to a wedding I think that's
where you we need to have more of a
cautionary tale because you can get this
this love bug right yeah you know you
got you got bridesmaids and groom
groomsmen
getting all enamored and I'm not saying
there's I'm not saying there's anything
wrong with it hammered in enamored I'm
just saying that's a that's a recipe
there's an awareness for disaster there
just needs to be an awareness if you're
the kind of person that you're like
actually I'm kind of trying you know
like I'm warm to the idea of getting
married and I'm trying to warm this
person up to the idea of getting married
I don't think that it's manipulative to
invite them to a friend's wedding or to
go to a friend's wedding with them but
you but it could it could work in your
favor if that's what you're after I just
think you have to and then if you're
like actually I am committed to not
fully committing to this relationship
and I don't want it to be I don't want
to get married well don't go to a
wedding make other plans that we I mean
you know what I'm saying yeah let's read
a tweet oh really because that's also a
thing that we can do Read It and Weep
this is from Invader Dizz
uh dizzy Wizard101 Daisy uh
I think this is easy I think it's
supposed to be my wife and I not my wife
and I because there's a whole different
question all right my wife and I went
miniature golfing with a group of
friends
where I plan to propose to her one of
the holes had a beautiful waterfall
feature now let's just I mean okay lots
of holes
so flowing water sexy instead of finding
a waterfall in nature the waterfall at
the Putt-Putt place was gonna do the
trick oh yeah so you kind of set
yourself up for what happened next and
there were friends there yeah yeah at
the moment I hit my knee a friend missed
a putt and threw his Club against the
fence yelling and cursing
but it does say my wife and I so
apparently
uh that now you know yeah that's that's
not a romantic scenario now this whole
idea of
popping the question
in making plans uh
this to me it it happened at the right
time it happened at the appointed time
it was a bad plan but it was a bad place
it was a bad plan sorry sorry dizzy
wizard you're a little bit dizzy here if
you had to do uh your proposal over
again would you have would you have
rigged it to where there was somebody
there taking photos of it
well
that's a great question considering that
that is such a part of the culture now
but it was not a part of the culture
and
99 I'm against this
you can take a photo afterward like a
selfie but like
I don't know I just think I think it's
weird
that's a good question because I think
what I would do now we've we've kind of
told our proposal stories before right
there was nobody present in mine it was
just the two of us going from place to
place to place and then ending up at the
place that we had actually first talked
and asking the question I think it was a
great plan I think it worked very well
yeah if there was a dude in the bushes
though
but if I were to be planning a proposal
now in the year 2023 which I'm not
um
I think it might involve some sort of
not public not public aspect I I would
like never long lens Paparazzi photo
type thing
I mean there's a type of Personality
that does a proposal at a baseball game
do you know what I mean all the
Jumbotron like if if there's a spectrum
of people and at one end of the spectrum
is someone who would ask someone to
marry them on a Jumbotron I whatever the
opposite end of that spectrum is that's
where I sit I'm no no no I do not want
to be on the Jumbotron I don't want to
be on the Jumbotron if I'm just eating
popcorn
but I don't want to be on the Jumbotron
yeah I hate being on the jumbo truck
that's why I don't like sports
um
but I think it's never a flattering
angle to document first of all I mean
your proposal story is is well is well
known and that it was completely
spontaneous
Sans ring no ring you know what because
I was planning to get the ring and then
popped the question and it was going to
be a complete surprise to everyone
except her parents and
um I never actually made plans like I
can't tell you like I I'm glad I didn't
I mean if I had that probably would have
I would have held off you know I'd be
like oh I got this thing all planned out
I didn't even get to that point I was
like I'll get the ring
in a week or two and at the same time
I'll also come up with a plan I I don't
know what my plan would have been like
uh if I think about it now put myself in
that situation which I've never done so
you didn't I don't know what my plan
would be you never had a plan no that's
what I just told you man there never was
any four thought it was uh get the ring
and then figure it out
or I'll figure it out while I'm getting
the ring
but then I was like you know what let's
just go for it I can't I mean it was an
overflow of emotion
it wasn't rational
what would I have done I don't I don't
know I don't know what I what what could
my it would have been awesome
um
what did we like to do back then
I don't
I think we might I don't know maybe we'd
have gone to the beach maybe we would
have watched the sun come up
you know
I have no clue
um I think it would have been one of
those things I mean you did some
creative things with like the Post-it
notes Etc and all yeah you know I had my
moments I Had My Moments it's
interesting that in that in that in that
scenario of
um
you know the groundwork that you had
laid the
proposal didn't have the same sort of
structure to it
yeah you weren't even planning on it
because it happened very quickly
I decided that I was going to propose
and then through like it was probably
three days later that I actually did it
worked out and it and and you know yes
it did right thank you and also
if somebody were to say like I'm not
going to marry you
because of the way that you asked me to
marry you you know that's that's not
somebody you want to be with right I
still this is actually a good segue to
this tweet right here oh
um from
pants damn tastic
I like that
I got stuck in traffic on route
to the Biltmore Estate all right largest
private residence in the United States I
love it where I was going to by the way
I think I've said this before I'll say
it again no one has ever contacted us
um I am interested
uh jumping off the roof of the Biltmore
Estate into a snow Dune and getting
access to the parts of the Biltmore
Estate that not everybody gets access to
okay I'm I'm also interested in that I
love the Biltmore Estate I've been there
several times I I love it too I love to
find and I know that there's a whole lot
of that estate y'all are keeping from
the public yeah we want we yep we want
to get in that's the part that I want to
see I don't want I've been in there
enough times in a big old line
I want to go to the secret parts
okay I'll make it worth your time
his foot rubs are amazing
so Biltmore Estate people
we're hey we're I'd like to retract that
statement we're North Carolina native
signs man
I mean I was born in Georgia but I was a
grew up in grew up in North Carolina you
you were born there he's born in Boone
Trail
you know what I'm saying come on I was
born in Durham
oh
Wikipedia says you were born in Boone
Trail it's not important Boone Trail I
think you were born at the Boone Trail
hospital no I wasn't my mom worked at
the Boone Trail hospital but then I was
born in Durham
oh well hold on this is a problem link
but yeah I guess I was I grew up my
first home was in Boone Trail
well right now it says that you were
born in Lillington North Carolina it
used to say Boone Trail
you need to get the wiki updated
well I mean that the hospital was in
Durham but like I was raised
my first home was outside of Lillington
in Boone Trail and Boone Trail okay this
guy was raised I would actually call it
Raven Rock so I think it's more
Lillington
okay that was that was I hope that was
worth it let's hear another voicemail I
haven't I haven't finished the I got
stuck on Biltmore Estate because I
really want to go to the back Parts yep
you you let's just go to another one no
panstamtastic was stuck in route to the
Biltmore Estate where I was going to
propose in the gardens oh they're
beautiful so we ended up pulling over
and I proposed
in the parking lot
behind burial brewing in Asheville
beside a sign that indicated you cannot
let your dog poop here
still she married me get her done so
this you guys where that phrase comes
you can relate to this
but I'm not going to I don't want to
associate myself with this guy
I'm skipping this one man I don't you
know there it is you read it all the way
um
[Music]
hey Rhett and Link I just saw your Tweet
about romantic mishaps and I immediately
thought of this one time I was in
college dating the sky thought he was
the love of my life he was finally
getting ready to meet my parents they
came from Pennsylvania uh to the state I
was going to college and basically just
to meet him and he played football at
the neighboring school that I was at and
I'm really excited I did my hair I did
my makeup I got ready at this point I
was 18 years old uh head over heels for
this guy and I'm scrolling on Twitter
listening to music just waiting for his
football game to get over on Saturday
because he was coming over that night
and we were doing brunch with my parents
brunch
um I was on schooling on Twitter there's
a viral tweet going around of a football
player jumping up into the stand getting
his girlfriend a really cute handshake
and basically wishing him luck for that
game I thought it was really really cute
I even think I favorite is the video the
girlfriend had tweeted it
um yet lo and behold it was him it was
the guy I was dating at the time's
girlfriend and I was really really upset
he was an hour away uh
the next town over and so I still made
him come I made him waste all of his gas
and as soon as he got there I basically
told him to turn around and I was really
upset about it for a really long time
but yeah I immediately thought of that
romantic mishap just being so excited
and that happening so that's it that's
me that's my life that's a good one
that's your life that def that like
that's what your life is like well
that's a piece of her life you know what
I I just want to celebrate that you kept
your power
you said you know what you're going to
come up here yeah come on come on to the
garage get out of the car smack I hope
there was like a slap involved it didn't
sound like there was there was there was
like a situational slap you burned your
gas
now turn around put your tail between
your legs and give your girlfriend that
secret handshake that everybody's
tweeting about well that would have been
the perfect thing to do the handshake
like to memorize in the hour oh yeah in
the hour that it took him to get there
to memorize the handshake so that as he
shows up you just go right into it and
he's like oh [__]
there's something sad about it though
it's like okay the whole way whole time
he's coming up you're watching
the video well this has become a
phenomenon not handshake uh cheaters
which is a different thing football
players going into the stands not that
specifically but basically being found
out via viral video so you may I mean a
number of these if this happens all the
time it's usually like sporting events
cheaters with public displays of
affection yeah on the Jumbotron
so there was one uh I don't know if it
was a World Cup Thing recently and the
guy listen first of all I'm glad the guy
got caught I'm glad that the cheater was
caught uh but he totally outed himself
because he's he's sitting there like
doing something with his girl or his
side girl and he sees himself on the
Jumbotron and like immediately like gets
nervous and like plays it off and tries
to look and everybody knows exactly what
he was doing if he had to just like not
played it off he would have never gone
viral it would have just been something
that happens at a sporting event and
just the people there you know what I'm
saying
he made himself go viral until then he
gets caught
again I'm glad he got caught probably
somebody in the stands who knew him
maybe he reported that but this has
become a phenomenon in which
through some sort of viral situation
that's how you get that's how you get
caught well shoot this one's very
specific well now I love jumbotrons I
think there this is this is they're
being used for good
do you think that before it was bad
that's what I said earlier in this
conversation yeah I didn't like them
do you think there's something morally
wrong with them no making people's faces
that big what yeah I said it's never a
good angle yeah nobody I'm part of this
podcast you should listen to me
occasionally well I'm trying to get you
to make the moral the moral argument for
it oh no I didn't have a moral argument
can what do you want me to click on now
um
you could just you should click on
number nine
hi Rhett and Link My name is Hannah and
I am responding to your Tweet about a uh
bad relationship Meetup uh situation
romantic plan thing so it was my uh
junior year of high school and I was
going to prom and my boyfriend at the
time had told me that he wanted to
surprise me with the place you were
going to for prom dinner and I was a
little nervous because he specifically
told me that he wanted to take his ex to
the same place which probably should
have been my first red flag and that she
really did not want to go but he
followed that story up with oh babe like
this just this place means so much to me
it's my favorite place like it's just
it's so romantic I just I want it to be
a surprise you just you're going to be
blown away You're gonna love it and so I
was like oh my gosh this guy is so sweet
he's like just really thinking this
tutorial and so I didn't ask I you know
was just let him plan it
um he hyped us up for months months this
man hyped this up and so prom night
rolls around and I'm putting on my the
fanciest dress I've ever freaking worn
and all the jewelry and my makeup done
and everything he picks me up and he's
like oh you're so gorgeous you take all
these pictures and I'm so excited we're
driving to this restaurant and he's like
I just can't wait for you to get here
it's so romantic
and he pulls into the parking lot of
longhorns
and not just does he pull into the
parking lot of Longhorn Steakhouse but
the man couldn't have even bothered to
make a reservation for LongHorn Steaks
so then we sat in the lobby of that
restaurant and we're just stared at by
all these families he's in a full talk I
mean there's a full like ball gown and
this man is in like a like a t-shirt
with paint all over it and ripji
and so yeah
don't always trust your date to plan uh
your prom dinner I guess
the good old Longhorn letdown
I'm assuming that the relationship
didn't continue did she say no it ended
at that moment
what do you think was going on here
like really like it's just just you know
forensically taste and standards and
just the inability to plan or
building it up all this time but just
not thinking just the guy a dummy I
think he's just probably stupid just a
dummy you know it's just like to build
it up yet not make reservations it's
just kind of like
short-sighted I remember a time choose
Longhorn
uh you know it's just a matter of taste
I remember when as we talked about
Chili's Outback these these are some
Fantastical exactly like I Outback which
I think is a little fancier than
Longhorns
I don't know what long I took Jesse to
out back on our first official date and
I thought not that it was hmm I don't
know if he uses her fancy but I thought
that it was much more expensive it was
pricey enough than anything that I had
bought for her because it was remember
that Valentine's Day dress up where we
like
where there was that place in Durham
that had a weird name that was like
really fancy Pearson parazade
and
you went there for Valentine's Day and
you look over and hear me and Christy
are walking into perazod we both made
reservations at the tables were right
next to each other when neither one of
us knew that we were going to the same
place for our Valentine's dates and we
had both planned it
the same person had told us we should do
it and that was a good place
I think that was a good Valentine's Day
but we didn't join up tables or did we
we did no no we talked a little bit but
it was about it wasn't about us
no but it made it a little weird it was
like well whose idea was this
hey man great minds think alike and we
both had this idea that perazod was a
really nice place
for some reason
and it was I mean I don't know I wonder
if that place is still open is it like
look I want to look at it and see how I
with how I would interact with this
place at this point
and just just spoiler alert we are so
spoiled like oh you know we just we like
to eat at like nice places okay yeah
it's still around is it what's the
what's the reviews
uh or first of all on Google is 4.5 with
810 reviews good so we're not spoiled
three dollar signs
and you can only get four
the description is upscale
locavore
locavore is that a word that I don't
understand I think it's people who like
to eat locally uh
upscale local War Mediterranean fare
prepared in an open kitchen and served
in an elegant dining room yeah see
listen even back then man we had to
drive all the way to Durham to go to a
place like that back in the day though
let's let's look what they have on the
menu and how much it costs
okay because I mean I I just want to
make the point that we're at time but
this seems like something to really dig
in well no I'm saying that like at that
time
we were I mean I had a very tight budget
my
my uh grocery budget for the for the
month was uh
either 200 or 250 dollars okay for all
groceries yeah we were we were both
married we were like newlyweds-ish
yeah 200
um definitely we try to do 200 well I
think you guys need to work on your
website Arizona
currently the server is down
uh pairs on durham.com oh it's a good
restaurant though
but that was a fan that was a fancy
place but it was it was the limit of
fancy uh for us and so I think we just
both sort of naturally conveyed there so
what have we learn today
talk about learning stuff
I don't know I kind of feel like you're
the one who should have learned
something uh I learned that you you
don't like the angles of faces on
jumbotrons because I listen to every
word that you say but I learned that you
don't think that I listen to you and
offend you oh there you go all right
what did you learn today let us know
using hashtag year biscuits or call us
180 earpod one you got a wreck for it I
do uh parazod
Durham North Carolina my wreck is a book
where I was born and uh the book is
called
Salito is this is this fact or fiction
it is a memoir
of Javier Zamora who
uh traveled
from El Salvador to the United States
um okay to be uh United with his parents
and it's just a really I mean first of
all I think it either it may have won
the Pulitzer Prize or was nominated it's
a great it's a great book like
really really well written and
captivating so he traveled he was a kid
at the time so yes and just basically
like the process like
I think it gives even though this was
written 20 years ago the situation
hasn't changed that much but just
learning about the story of people uh
coming across the southern border and
like what their lives are like why
they're doing that what it's like for
them what that experience can be like
I knew bits and pieces about how some of
this you know works but to hear a
personal account told in a very
compelling way was
it was very eye-opening for me celito a
memoir by Javier Javier Zamora are you
recommending the audible version as well
I did not listen to it I actually read
it which is uh you know which is unusual
for me at this point in my life I
actually read the book I'm sure that the
audible version is great but I recommend
also just actually reading it yeah
especially if you have jury duty a lot
of people showing up with actual
physical what were you doing to kill the
time uh I have my air pods and I made
some doctor's appointments for myself
okay and I listened to some music some
High Fidelity music yeah I did I did I
listened to some music yeah
and I listen to some tick tocks
haha
we'll see you next week
through
you know all the way through the
Research Triangle all that stuff stuck
in some bumper-to-bumper traffic and
there's an old white Pontiac in front of
me and the license plate is a vanity
license plate and it says Merle Hagg
m-e-r-l space h-a-g and who knows maybe
it's Merle Haggard anyways love y'all
thanks so much bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]